Oh, hello, hello, everyone.
Hi, Freshel, Liquid, Roy, Dylan, Michael, Astro, Rees, Pug,
Victor, Ruby, Rees, every, uh, did I say Ed?
Ed, hi, everyone.
Okay, so, um, when I started, when I, when I picked this
game, and also, hey, Stevie, when I picked this game, I was
like, oh, it looks cute.
That looks cute, because I saw someone else playing.
I was like, oh, it looks so cute.
Look, it's Pixlr, and, like, she's in a house.
and oh it's like an adventure game it's like a puzzle game
and then i was like i'm gonna play this on stream and then i
um i put the tags down on the stream i i was changing
categories and the first tag that showed up was horror and i
was like how is this horror it's a fucking pixel game how So
I was like, oh fuck I mean it's kind of puzzle game With
more panic I guess Oh shit Puzzles and horror Oh no That's
the worst combination So I Hey obviously also thank you so
much for the follow up prototype I do appreciate it Thank
you thank you Have a have a but heart Thank you so much
Alright so apparently I'm going to be doing puzzles We'll
have a time limit, and it's going to be scary.
So all three things, all my worst traits combined together.
That's great.
I'm very much looking forward to it.
So we're not, you're not late yet.
I haven't started the playthrough yet.
Because I want to like procrastinate a bit.
Because apparently the game's like 30 minutes long, and
there's like a time limit.
So I basically have 30 minutes.
To not die, which that means there's gonna be many attempts.
There's gonna be many attempts on this Because there's a
time limit too and it's 30 minutes so I don't fucking know
how I'm gonna go through this Cause first of all there's
puzzles in there and I'm gonna get chased and then I'm
somehow have to like Make sure you know what I don't even
care if I get the worst ending I just want to finish this
game I don't even I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get the worst
fucking ending also hey classic
Are you guys ready for me to start the game?
I'm not ready.
I have no idea what the plot of the story is.
I just noticed that you're a girl.
It's pixel art and it's spooky.
That's all I know.
I'm trying to time to sleep before the trip tomorrow.
Me right now sleeping in the plane.
It is.
All right.
Spooky pixel art.
Oh, okay.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, hey.
Oh Oh, I'm here.
How do I move?
Arrow keys?
What the fuck uses arrow keys?
What the fuck?
Hey, I'm a cute girl.
All right.
Okay, we don't read here.
Oh, thank you so much.
We're not no gotcha today.
Oh, Astra.
So apparently there's like a time too.
So it's 9.
Okay, it's 9.50.
There's no gotcha today, Astrum.
Sorry, fucking get scammed.
Also, should I be, like, looking at the...
Alright, how do I open the door?
Hold shift to sprint.
Oh!
Rob!
Hey, here you go, Rob.
Just for you.
Get scammed, Astia.
Are you hungry?
I'll make some sandwiches.
Okay.
What's in here?
You're hungry.
Thank you so much for the follow!
Artenza, I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a... I know there's a time limit, but fuck it.
Dude, this is a 30...
I can't believe you've done this.
I wish I could stay longer, but I don't want to go to sleep.
Alright, it's okay, Ed.
I do appreciate you coming...
Oh, hey, cat.
Meow.
I do appreciate you coming over and hanging out with us.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
His dad will come home at midnight and you have a mom and a
sister.
Well, I apparently have a cat, too.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to turn...
Turn the volume down.
It is so fucking loud in my ears.
I did.
I can pour this?
What do I do with this?
Is this milk?
What am I holding?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I got a key.
Wait, no?
How do I get a key?
Key?
Oh, key.
Hey.
I hate this house.
Alright, fine.
Oh wait, I can...
Item?
Yeah, little card!
Where'd I go?
Okay, so...
Oh!
Oh god!
Okay, okay, bye.
Chicken out.
What's this?
Yeah.
Oh, it just starts a game.
okay all right so we don't go in there we don't go in the
rat room I've learned that rat room is dangerous the rat
room is a is a no-no room
I'm watching you sleep that's not creepy at all I don't have
siblings so I don't know if it's a is it normal watch your
siblings sleep because I don't have I'm an only child so I
don't know I don't know if that's a normal thing to do I'm
gonna have dinners all be lurking alright alright I need the
milk milks I don't really have a choice when you share a
room so do you watch your do you watch your sister sleep
when you're in the room together that's really creepy but
I'm also an only child
How do I... How do I pick up items?
Oh, A.
I...
Alright, so I learned that I don't go into that room.
That room's a no-no room.
Wait, okay, but, like, my mom's gonna make me food, right?
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Where the fuck do I go with this key?
There's only, like, three doors.
Here?
Like, how big is this house?
How big is this fucking house?
What?
There's only, like, seven rooms.
I don't know how to count, though.
I assume there's, like, seven.
Okay, okay, if I pick this up and then I leave, I should be
fine, right?
Press space to open the...
Okay, I have a bucket.
What the fuck do I do with a bucket?
Okay.
I am so flucking.
Please, can I have some food now?
Please, mom.
Can I have some more?
Can I have some- oh!
Okay, are you okay?
Are you okay?
I'm so okay.
Oh!
That's what the bucket was for!
Well, I tried.
Oh!
Oh, my sister's dead too!
Whoops Whoops I'm not a very good.
I'm not a I'm not a very good child
You don't oh, hey there.
What is this?
Oh, okay Oh and shadow man.
Hey shadow man
Apparently I'm not very good at saving people I'm Not very
good at this.
Oh, the shadow went.
At least she died.
Why, sir, don't you hate it when that happens?
Man, don't you hate it when you slip and you just die?
Don't you just hate that?
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
Okay, I need to give milk milkies to the cat.
How is I supposed to know this is a puddle?
It's just fucking three thingies.
It's just like three dots on the floor.
What the fuck?
What child would know what that is?
Thank you so much for the follow milkshake.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Have a mother.
Maybe we can get some...
Dude, I already... Azer.
They've already died.
Several...
Excuse me?
Oh my god.
I gave you milk and this is how you repay me?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Good chat.
Wait, how do I pick up?
Oh, hey.
I keep forgetting how to...
How to pick- please feed me.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, but like, where did I get the bucket?
I have?
Oh, he's this.
Oh yeah, I can like look through- look through their things,
right?
I am so fucking confused.
How is this a 30-minute game?
People already died in like less than five minutes.
I don't understand how people can play this game for 30
minutes People already die in 30 in like five minutes Oh,
hey, whoa, whoa shadow man Thank you so much for the follow
it you go.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you
Hello, oh shadow man.
Why shadow man?
Oh shit, we need to get the bucket.
I need to save my mom How do I oh
I did this Okay, how do I pick you up mom look what I did?
Look what I did mom.
Oh
Well then okay
Okay Wait, but how do I save my oh Okay
Okay.
Bye.
I'm not very good at this, guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Here?
Hey.
How do I...
How do I get out?
Hello.
Okay.
Well, then, now that my mom and my sister is dead...
Oh!
What the fuck!
Okay.
Hi mom Okay Well, she's, hey, she didn't die She's okay
Alright Now I know why it took 30 minutes For now I know why
it took 30 minutes chat Now I know why this game took 30
minutes Alright, alright, alright I got this, okay, okay So
I have to get to the Okay I forgot to defrost the turkey
before my mom gets home.
Okay, but how do I get- Oh!
Okay, okay, I need a- I need cats for- to get the milk.
All right, all right, all right, I got this.
We can speed run this now.
This time I won't fuck up, I swear.
All right, cat, wake up.
Wake the fuck up.
Wake up, cat.
This time, this will be the speed run.
This is it.
This is- I'm- you're gonna see what- AGLS is playing right
now.
AG-L-8 is AG- SLSG is playing right now.
They're gonna fucking submit my speedrun.
And I'm gonna be on stream.
Please.
Wake up.
I need the key.
Okay, please stop talking to me.
Please.
Give me the key.
Okay, and then...
And then we do this.
And then we go out here.
Who the fuck is Shadow Man?
I'm so confused over...
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, I think already fucked up.
Wait, how do I?
How do I, how do I?
Oh, I think already fucked up.
Wait, how do I, how do I save my mom?
Wait, I fucked up already!
Wait, I think I already fucked up!
How do I, how do you mop this?
Okay, okay, wait, if I keep slipping on it.
Oh, if I keep slipping in it, will it dry out?
Will it dry?
Okay, alright mom, sorry.
That's how you do it, right?
Mom, I'm sorry, mom!
I'm so sorry!
If I keep slipping on it, will it help?
I'm sorry!
Oh, wait, I can save my sister!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
Alright, alright, okay, bye.
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
I have to keep slipping!
I have to keep slipping on it to save her!
Holy shit!
I am the fucking smartest gamer out there, okay.
Oh!
Oh, okay, bye.
Um, hey, okay.
Well then.
Okay.
And then I drop it here for the rat.
Ratty.
Rat.
I got you food, rat.
I got you food!
Please eat my food!
Yeah.
Oh.
All right, you know what?
I wanted to be an only child.
I want it to be an only child anyway.
Shit.
It's okay.
I want it to be an only child.
I'm okay with that.
He's on top of her.
Oh.
Cat, are you okay?
What's that?
Cat?
Is Cat okay?
Oh, cat.
dead oh shit we can't stay wait oh I'm so sorry wait where's
mom mom
oh no what
does this do swing let me swing hey mom oh
I see you've never played a hard game You hear your hard
play Why do you lie?
I think I think I got bored
Well then Oh I didn't Not understand how this took 30
minutes To fucking play Damn she bored me Oh Okay, alright.
I now know how to save my mom.
I don't know what to do with my sister, though.
I don't think I need a sister.
I don't think I need a sister, so that's okay.
Drink the milk.
Wake up.
Are you not afraid?
Perfect with this.
Yeah, sisters are optional.
We don't need a sister.
That means more presents for me.
to have siblings and I think I like I like being an only
child so she can be squished I think I think like being an
only child is pretty fun I get to have I was gonna say
something really fucked up I'm saying like what are you
gonna do huh I'm their only child they can't do shit they
can only rely on me Hey Rain!
Okay, I need to cycle the items.
Okay, and I gotta slip on it.
I gotta slip on it, so...
Hey Taylor!
Okay, if I slip on it, it'll be okay.
I just gotta keep slipping.
Just gotta keep slipping.
Sorry this makes you feel incurred by mine.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Okay, and then...
And then what do I do?
I pick it up?
What if I just do this?
Oh.
Okay, apparently not like that.
Okay, then I just gotta keep slipping.
Also, these were your little follow, Taylor.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, mom.
Mom, give me some sandwiches.
Oh, the buckets were the cat!
Oh!
all right mom i did it
okay and then i gotta i gotta pick up the sandwich for the
uh for the for the for the rat all right rat here's a
sandwich get in here get in here oh she's dead okay okay
well she's dead now let me i don't give a fuck about you for
now let me go save the Let me go save the cat.
I'm sorry, sister.
I don't care about you.
Alright, anyway.
There's a fucking...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sandwich, sandwich, sandwich.
Eat the sandwich.
Yes, yes, yes, there we go.
Alright.
Alright, we got everything.
We got everything we want to do.
Alright, oh, okay.
We have everything we need.
All right, we don't care about the girl.
Okay, so the cat's alive.
Do you remember me?
I actually don't, Mike.
I actually don't.
I'm sorry.
All right, and now we gotta swing the axe.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh!
Wait!
What what's that sound?
Well,
I have another sandwich I pick up the sandwich no
All right, oh oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh please
Oh,
okay, never mind.
Hey Arlo How the fuck do you beat this game?
I don't understand How do I how do I beat this game?
Do I just stay in the rap?
room i'm just gonna stay in the rat room i'm just gonna
all right i don't know how to save the sister i don't know
how to save the mom as long as i save the cat that's all
that matters that's all that looking matters i just need to
save the cat always safe in the rat room all right just stay
in the rat room the rat room is safe but like Alright, cat.
The rat and the cat.
The only family we need.
This is apparently it is.
I don't know.
Apparently.
It is a horror game.
Oh, look.
These are the follow firestone.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alright, cat.
Get the fuck up.
Cat.
I need the.
I need the key.
Cat.
Oh, there we go.
Thanks, cat.
Okay.
Alright, then I need a bucket.
Like an only chest.
out simulator.
I mean, you're not wrong.
You're not wrong.
You're not wrong about that.
All right.
Okay, I just need to slip on it a few times.
I just need to slip on it a few times.
There we go.
Okay.
What happens if I turn up the lights?
All right, green.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
How do I do this?
Can I push the...
No, I can't.
I guess, whoa, bye sister.
I guess I don't have a sister anymore.
Bye bye.
I need that sandwich.
Um...
What the fuck do I...
Oh, wait, what's this bullet ball?
Oh!
Do I do it?
Do...
Oh!
What do I do here?
Well then, bye.
I guess I do that?
We don't have a sister anymore, so that's okay.
Alright, bye.
Oh shit, wait, I need to pick this up.
Alright.
Yeah, my cat's my family now.
Bye, sister.
Please, please eat the sandwich.
Let's go.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, no, no, please Please I just want to make it I just want
to I just want to be saved
Please I just want to be saved Channel
Did how many times do I have to do this?
I want to People speeder on this game How do you do it?
Okay, all right trial and error There is a lot of trial and
error.
There's a lot of errors.
There's a lot of errors
Okay, oh no All right, we don't need we don't need rat room
we don't need rat room fuck you yeah I fucked it up already
okay if I keep doing this will the ghost be angry it's okay
we don't need rat we don't need who's on this house I have
several complaints you know what I okay I just realized wait
can I die from this oh I can Ah, well then.
Well then.
I can die from this.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Speed run.
Let's speed run this.
Wait, I can't believe we've only been streaming this game
for five minutes, chat.
Holy shit, I am a fucking guy.
Alright, we need this.
And then my cat.
Please, here we go, and then...
And then, wake up.
Hey, movie!
Okay, and then I drop you here.
And then I need to get the milk.
I might go doing...
Like, I am actually, like, doing this on autopilot now.
This is on fucking autopilot.
Please.
Cat, wake up.
Cat, please.
I need the key.
Please, Cat.
Please.
No.
This is an actual speedrun now.
Bike rat.
Okay, and then I need a...
What a lovely house.
Only 12 horrific murders took place.
Exactly.
Only 12.
I think we have a very good track record.
It's only 12 deaths.
Not that much.
What the fuck do I do here?
I want to...
want to save my okay i don't really give a shit about my
sister but like uh it would be nice if my sister didn't die
oh me thank you so much for the for the for the raid thank
you thank you okay sister sister please sister please oh
what if i just keep talking to you sister if i keep talking
to you will you not die do you have a good stream on me all
right if i keep talking to you will you be okay look i hate
what he did i hate these walls look if I keep talking to you
you'll be alive right please don't die please stop playing
the piano if you just stop playing oh shit wait wait wait I
just realized wait wait wait oh I think she's gonna die from
this oh she's fine okay and I can't die right exactly isn't
that how it works what the fuck is this frog doing here what
do I do with this frog you saved her Messiah thank you so
much for the follow thank you thank you have a blood hearts
have some blood hearts all right oh shadow man hey shadow
man I don't I don't know how to pick the frog up.
Well, we don't give a fuck about the frog, apparently.
So, okay there.
So the sister's gonna die, and I don't know what to do about
that.
I don't know what I can do about the sister's death.
She's dead.
Now eat your sandwich.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's the sandwich.
Please, I just eat the sandwich.
Alright, so that was karma, because I was like, bye bye
sister, and I...
He's all your little follow, Hannah.
Dude, how the fuck?
You said you were meaning this, but how the fuck do you do
this?
Everyone just keeps dying.
You guys hear my little frog, champ.
Why do people keep dying around me?
I don't understand.
All right, and then here's the milk.
What to do with you?
What are you gonna do with you?
Here you go.
Cat, wake up.
I need the key.
I don't- I've been playing for 36 minutes.
I've been doing this for 36 minutes.
Is this insanity?
Is this- I thought I could- Daniel just wanted to get an
ending.
I don't care how many people die.
I just want this game to end.
Oh,
I should...
Okay, but then she's gonna die through the bear trap.
I don't care how many people I sacrifice.
I just want to end this game.
I just want this game to end.
Hey, please, please, please stop.
Okay, so I got everything I need.
I just don't know how to...
Is she gonna die?
Oh!
Well then, at least she's okay.
At least she's not crushed.
That's alright.
She's okay.
Oh, shit.
Do I crush the frog?
Alright, frog.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Well then.
It's okay, I saved her.
She's safe.
And then I take this.
And then...
It's okay.
She's okay.
I think being...
I think dying from a bear trap is...
Look, she's happy.
Oh!
Oh, she's not happy!
She's not happy!
I don't think she was...
happy guys okay she was definitely not happy
oh sorry I'm sorry
okay so what I've learned was that she was uh she was not
happy she she was definitely not oh please I can't run oh no
Please.
Right, eat the sandwich.
Please eat the sandwich.
Oh, oh, no.
Please do.
Why can't you eat the sandwich?
All I want you to do is eat.
Why can't you eat?
You're like, you're making...
I thought I got it down.
I thought I got everything down.
Sastron, thank you so much for the follow.
You appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay, I got this down.
Did he just say, oh, you just rub your face too close to the
mouth?
Okay.
How do I even save her?
I don't understand.
What do I do with this?
Okay, if I put it here, it should be okay, right?
Alright, I'll put this here for now.
And then...
Okay, alright, alright.
Come on, my cat.
Look up!
Thank you.
Okay, and then I gotta go get...
Easy ride.
Doesn't make Chan nasty from no sister killer.
I just wanted to be an only child!
Is my mom gonna die?
Oh no, she's okay.
Okay.
Is that too much to ask for?
I just want it to be an only child.
I'm gonna call it here.
My back is killing me today.
Have fun.
Don't murder anyone else.
Oh, I don't know about that.
I kill a cat here?
No, I shouldn't.
I guess the cat's the only one I know how to keep alive.
So I-
No, you feed the rat the sandwich.
But then I don't know what else to do after that.
I don't know how to save my sister.
So, it's okay.
We don't care about her.
We just want the sandwiches.
I can.
I try to.
I try to crush it.
Alright, I haven't killed the mom.
But the mom just disappears.
So, I don't know where the fuck she goes.
Also, thank you so much for the follow link.
So, I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, mom.
Give me that sandwiches.
So I can feed the rat.
Check it so I can feed the rat again.
But like, it worked with the- Also, thank you so much for
the followers.
It worked with the- It worked last time.
I just don't know why it's not working now.
The rat for some reason doesn't want to eat my sandwiches
for some reason.
I don't know why.
I think my sandwiches are perfectly good.
Right, bye.
Alright, here.
Here.
Here's the rat.
Here it is.
Yes, he's- Okay, oh my god, I'm a shadow man, please shadow
man, please I just got it to work shadow man, please
Well, I don't care about you
I was gonna be so angry I I work to shadow man, please I
just got this place I just all right anyway anyway and then
what do we do here all right and then i do like put it here
somewhere oh she's oh she okay
wake up mom mom oh oh oh bye mom oh
so that's where mom oh okay how do i how do i do this okay
so that's where mom went how do I get rid of this how do I
do this please Oh, Shadow Man.
Shadow Man.
Please.
I just wanted to get- Oh, here I did it.
Oh, man, thank you so- Is that it?
What do I do?
What do we do now?
Thank you so much, you saw it, but you do appreciate it.
What do I do?
Daddy's home.
Hey, Daddy.
Okay, there's a bear shop.
Yeah.
Dumbass.
Oh, I'm the dumbass.
I'm the dumbass.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh.
You're gonna use it when I don't follow Um, the dumbass Ah
I'm so sad I'm so sad I can't believe I thought I got it I
thought it was I thought it was like 800 IQing this shit I
thought I was so smart.
I thought I was so smart.
How do I do this?
I didn't appreciate you bear trapping this boy.
I was like, he's dead.
So mom gets eaten by a fridge and dad's up is a face eating
four of them, man.
No, this family's got it all.
Thank you so much.
I do appreciate it, thank you.
All right, cat.
Eat your milk.
Get the fuck.
Dude, I hate how like this takes 20 years.
It takes him 20 years to get his cat ass off.
Like the cat's the only one I can save.
I can't even tell this is a horror game where a make people
never win game.
I'm never gonna win.
It's similar to man get caught in the bear trap.
Okay, well It still goes to KSC, learn something new every
time So as long as you keep learning, experiment I see
that's progress, exactly Exactly The only thing is that Our
sister doesn't live, but that's okay I just want, I've
always wanted to be an only child I've always wanted to be
an only child That's okay
Like I tried to do something about it But look, just let me
do anything I can't I can't save him so it's fine.
I don't need her I what does she even do for this my house
nothing like what do I kill the frog?
I also learned that you can kill the frogs, but it doesn't
do shit Like it just comes back.
Oh, thank you so much.
It'll follow candy.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
What do I need?
Oh, I need sandwiches.
Yes You're doing great sweetie.
I'm trying my best Drop me the bullet bomb cat floor with
the cat faster I don't think so.
I tried dropping it before.
Happy birthday, Snake!
Can we get some happy birthdays in chat for Snake real
quick?
Here we get some happy birthdays.
Oh, Shadow Man.
Hey, Shadow Man.
Okay, alright, I have the sandwich.
Rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat.
Use your dumbass sandwich here.
Rat, rat, rat!
No, no, shadow man, shadow man.
All right, now we gotta, uh, we gotta, we don't care about
you.
Bye.
And then we gotta get the, we gotta get the, oh shit, wait,
wait, wait, wait, we gotta do this.
We gotta, boom, boom, bottom, bottom, boom.
All right, and then we gotta go get the axe.
Yeah, but I could always come back in.
I could always come back.
What?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, there you go, we're fine, we're fine, we
don't care about the sister, okay, we may have, I can save
my, I may have saved my mom, I can save my mom, don't worry,
mom, don't worry, mom, I'll chop her hand, mom, I'll save
you, too, mom, look at this, watch this, mom, look at this,
I got this, yeah, yeah, Yeah!
Oh!
You're welcome.
You don't give a fuck.
Oh shit, Shadow Man.
I did it!
I saved mom!
Okay, alright, alright.
I did it.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
There we go.
I'm so good at this game.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What do I do now?
Okay, what do I do now, though?
I don't know what to do.
Mom!
All right, all right, okay, okay, I got this.
All right, dad's gonna be here.
Daddy's home.
Yeah, get in here.
Get in here.
Ah, stupid.
Yeah, that's right.
Whoa, dad.
I got mom.
Don't worry, I have mom.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have mom!
Ha-ha!
What are you gonna do?
Mom!
I saved your life!
What the fuck's the point of saving mom?
What the fuck was the point?
What the fuck was the point of saving mom?
She's not gonna do shit.
I'm so sad.
Alright, so mom can die.
At least I learned mom can die mom mom can die.
We don't need to give a fuck about her
We don't need to give a fuck about mom All those efforts
wasted on her was the point all she all she's good for is
making sandwiches Cat oh it does wake him up Roy you were
right.
I'm sorry for doubting you Okay All right, so I woke up cat.
All right, get your badass off.
All right, and then I need I need key.
I need key.
All right, and then and then I need to unlock key.
And then I need to pick this up.
And then I need to, what the fuck do I need to do?
Um, oh yeah, I need to cycle this and drop it here.
All right.
Oh shit, yeah, I should try that.
So it doesn't even become half- half-manies.
Can I?
No, nothing drops there.
What if I do this to my mom?
What happens?
Mom.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, mom doesn't give a fuck, apparently.
Mom doesn't care.
Alright.
Give me the bear trap.
Give it to me.
Alright.
What the fuck do I do with this?
Okay, and then I need to wait until What do I do here?
Oh, I just wait.
I just need sandwiches.
I just need I just need the sound.
I don't give a fuck about light switches I Oh, it's spooky
now.
Oh, it's spooky.
Oh, what are you gonna do?
What if I turn off the lights here?
Sister, are you gonna keep playing in the dark?
Don't be dumb.
Don't play in the dark.
Sister, is this annoying?
sister okay she doesn't give a shit
well i don't know i've given up i just need we don't need
her we don't need her guys all we need is our cat all we
need is our fucking cat we don't need anyone else all right
apparently this is due shit anyway so and then sandwich.
Here.
Eat the sandwich.
You can stop.
Yeah, that's right, bitch.
Okay.
I'm sorry for calling you a bitch.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Yeah, bitch.
I don't know what to do after this.
Alright.
You know what?
I'll save the mom.
I have nothing else to do right now.
Mom, you're lucky.
I have nothing else to do.
Oh, she's asleep.
Mom, you're lucky.
I have nothing else to do right now.
What do I do?
Can I just kill her?
Whoa!
Well then.
Okay, bye.
You know what?
Oh, oh, I forgot the
cat!
Oh, oh, no!
I forgot the cat!
I'm so sorry!
Oh.
Oh, I killed the cat and the mom.
Look, I just need, I need this to fucking hurry up.
Look, it's not my fault.
Shadow Man, I don't have time for your shit.
I don't know.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
All right, I need to swing my hammer.
Do this?
What?
I just wanted to open the closet.
I just wanted to...
Girl, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you.
I got worried again.
Well, we don't need the mom.
We've learned that we don't need the mom.
We don't need the sister.
We might need the cat, but I forgot about the cat there.
I keep forgetting.
How do I do this shit?
Alright, so we don't need a lot of people.
We just need the cat.
I hope you had a good stream, Crow.
I hope you had a good stream.
Alright, alright.
Don't worry.
Bam.
Yeah, that's right.
Wake the fuck up, cat.
We don't need- Yeah, we don't need anyone other than the cat
and the rat.
What do you mean, back?
I did!
I hugged the back wall and then she bored me!
She bored me!
Did you not see the board?
I was at the back!
This is the back!
I was over here!
I was...
was right here and then she boarded me with the cat and the
rat it's gonna be some interesting PDA meetings okay what am
I doing oh shit wait okay boom oh that's just not it boom
there you go there's always a follow word I do appreciate it
thank you thank you hmm no no no you put the sandwiches you
put the sandwiches on the rat is he gonna sandwich his
sister do anything Do we care about the sister though?
I don't...
We don't care about the sister though.
Like, I'm not gonna do shit about her.
I'm not gonna save her life.
You know what?
Oh, hey.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I wanna kill the frog.
I don't know what it does, but I just wanna kill the frog.
Oh, wait, that's not it.
Wait, that's not it.
I don't understand.
Spatial.
Wait.
Can I... Why can't I pick it up?
Oh, the frog has the bull and ball now.
Well then.
I guess the frog has the bull and ball now.
And then I'll hit you down here.
Alright.
Alright, I need my sandwiches.
Now is it too near to deconfirm?
I can't pick up the bull and ball anymore.
I don't think they want me to crush the frog.
I don't think they like that.
Now I can save the mom.
well I don't really care about the mom, to be honest so all
we're gonna do is uh kill every guy is scary to be honest no
no no no no this is all planned like I didn't kill anyone
she just died she's just dumb to be fair I didn't kill
anyone she's just stupid
okay all right I need to save the cat I just need to save
the cat Okay, I just need to save the cat.
Okay, alright, I saved the cat.
I did it.
Alright, alright, alright.
And then... I guess I could save mom too.
I guess...
I guess I could save the mom too.
Bye.
No, she doesn't go in.
She doesn't... I poured water on her and then she freaked
out and died.
I'll save the mom once, okay?
I'll save her again please come out please come out
yeah yeah yeah yeah stupid all right and then we gotta
and then we gotta do this thing all right i'm just gonna
wait until this works can you pick up no i tried picking up
the sandwich but i can only pick up one i have no idea we
don't care with the mom like she has nothing for me I I I
like led dad over and then dad he was just like bye you're
liar you liar you fucking liar oh hey daddy's home too oh
hey look at that he's oh hey yo daddy's home
Yo, thanks, dad.
Yeah, they get us easier.
They get us easier.
Never trust Roy.
Oh, he's home with both ours, and it's not like her.
Hey, look, it's okay.
Mom's still alive.
I saved mom.
That's all that matters, right?
I fucking saved that bitch.
Alright.
Please.
Please, get the fuck away.
Alright.
Okay, and then...
Wait, how do I...
Okay, and then pick up.
And then...
And then what do I do?
Oh yeah, okay, okay, okay.
I gotta...
I just wanna...
Let me win this game, please.
I don't care that people are dead.
I don't care that I've killed I've killed many people.
I can't.
I have to wait for the sandwiches.
I have to wait for the sandwiches for the rat.
And then...
Alright.
How do we distract the lady from the bathroom?
I don't know.
I don't know what to do about that.
I need...
okay so so I don't know what to do here I'm stuck here this
is where I'm stuck at guys well maybe if I do I go to my
sister's room sister sister yes I know you hate your life
like there's nothing I can do here though in her room yeah
her room is meaningless I have to I have to get the saddle
though I don't have the sandwiches other space I have no
idea I can't I can't um I can't go in the room without my
sandwiches because of the rat I need their sandwiches so the
rat will will be satisfied it won't be me and it grows I
made sandwiches and then okay so okay I'll show you guys
what I did last time because we don't give a fuck about the
we don't really give a fuck actually no actually no I'm not
I don't I want to save the cat I want to save the cat so I
want I actually sort of want to save the cat so here take
this raise thank you so much for the gift this up to Elstar
get some bark nights real quick get some bark nights real
quick for for Elstar okay and then we put this and then we
don't give a fuck about the mom.
We don't give a fuck about it.
Use your spring, you can grab the axe just to throw the rack
and get you and cut the boards.
Well, that, I don't give a fuck.
I just, maybe if I lead the dad, if I lead the dad to crazy
lady, then maybe she'll war him instead of me.
Right?
Maybe she'll war him.
Oh, I forgot the cat again!
I forgot the cat again!
I'm sorry I forgot the cat again I'm so sorry Oh what the
fuck
Oh he did not like that He didn't like that I forgot the cat
Oh he was not happy about that He was not happy about that
He's your only family.
I told you this was...
You would think that.
You would think that this was supposed to be a 30-minute
game.
It was a fucking lie.
Angry.
Shadow Man was not happy.
He was not happy about that.
Okay.
Alright.
If I do this...
Boom.
And then I'll get the axe first, right?
You guys want me to try getting the axe first, right?
Okay, let's try.
Let's try this Just don't use my sprint.
I just don't use my sprint.
I just don't use my sprint Whoa you liar
Am I just bad at this game like
You have to time it.
God damn.
Me and time.
Wake the fuck up.
Man, I think boss is huge.
I just want to...
I just want...
What's the easiest way to win this game?
I don't care.
What is the easiest way to win this game?
I don't care how many people die.
I don't care how many people...
It's hard.
Oh my god.
I don't care how many people die in this world.
I just want to win.
I just want this game to be over.
I need to sleep right at your work tomorrow.
Watch the mod and see how long it took you to get to the
game.
All right, all right, all right.
Thanks for reading it.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I hope we have a good night's rest for your work tomorrow.
All right.
But it's what you have but it's what you have to do it.
I have to do that to win the game Please is there no other
way?
Is there no other way?
Okay, I'll do it again.
Oh no, actually, no, I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna just gonna do my usual strat I'll do my usual
strat
Yeah, but then what about that?
What about dad though?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, all right, all right.
Oh,
and then I can, I can like, I know.
Oh, I see, I see.
And then, um, um.
Oh, I know.
I know, I know, I got this, my brain.
My brain is getting bigger.
I know what to do, I know what to do.
Yeah, okay, and then I pick this up, and then...
Oh, but then I'm gonna save the sister!
Then I'm gonna save the sister!
We don't give a fuck about the sister!
Alright, sister, here's your stupid sandwich.
Sister, I got you a sandwich!
Is she gonna die?
Whoa!
Well then.
I got your sandwich sister.
Well, it appears that...
It appears that it didn't work.
Guys, it appears that the sandwich did not want a night
living.
That wasn't it.
Well then.
Oh
Sandwich does not save the sister.
Well, I've learned I've learned that how do I win this how
do I fucking win this?
Please someone backseat please backseat this game for me
I hate backseat gamers
This is just pain this is just pain at this point Wait, all
I feel is pain.
I swear, okay, if we don't figure out a solution by the
15-minute mark, we're fucking done with it.
We're fucking folding up a tutorial.
We've been stuck on this one area.
I have a doll?
Oh, wait, I should save my mom first.
I should...
But I don't want to save...
Okay, but the thing is, I don't need to save my sister.
My sister is optional.
Like, we don't need her.
There's no reason to have her in our lives.
Oh, should I need the bowling ball?
We don't need the sister in our lives.
So that's just an optional thing.
I want to be an only child.
Just kill her with a bear trap bar.
What if it's up, but then what if I'm dead?
What if I'm dead?
Whoa!
Will you hold me?
Okay.
Bye.
My sister.
Oh, she doesn't want you.
Yeah, that guy's new.
Yeah.
What if I put her in the room?
I'll put her in there.
I'll just drop her here once.
Will you hold me?
Yeah.
Why?
Alright, now she's just gonna play the song.
What is the dog gonna do?
Yeah, but the...
Alright.
Hey.
Okay, so she doesn't give a fuck, so I'm just gonna leave.
Oh, would war lady like her?
What are you here?
Oh, wait, I need the sound.
Okay.
I don't know what to do now.
we got this down okay and then i need i need sandwich all
right we don't care about we don't care about sister we
don't care about
unredeemable exactly we don't need her boom eat your
sandwich stupid here we go all right now rats happy whoa
whoa i'm not happy
All right, and then we gotta do this thingy.
Whoa, but wait, but I need to drop this thingy.
Okay, so we settle on how to deal with dad first round.
How the fuck do I deal with dad's second round?
Wow, I don't know how to deal with dad's second round.
So...
The cat!
Oh!
all right here i'll hold you what do i do with you all right
i drop you here you go all right all right okay so all we
have is just wait until midnight now
oh shadow man i don't need you oh i see mom do i see mom i
might as well i'm here all right and then i turn on the
lights and then now what do I do.
I don't know what to do now.
I guess I wait?
Oh, hey.
Dad.
I did everything I could.
Oh, Shadow Man.
Dad.
Oh.
Doll fell down.
Why did doll fell down?
Why did doll fall down?
I just want one end user.
I just want one ending.
Alright, daddy.
Alright, dad.
Man, I'm waiting.
Daddy's home.
Alright, dad.
Just go into this trap.
Go into this trap.
Woo!
Bye-bye!
Hey, dad.
I'm right here!
Woo!
What the fuck was that?
I was sorry that you switched to the gift and stuff to Acer.
Hey, I think you use the park nights real quick.
XA, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you so much for the follow.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, you know what?
I don't know what the fuck I'm gonna do.
I can destroy the toilet in the bathroom.
Alright, let's destroy the fucking toilet with the bowling
ball.
I was like, here, I think you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Well, the doll is fucking useless.
We don't give a shit about the doll.
So she was useless.
Going to work, but I can't make it into, I can't though.
Look, it won't let me go in.
It's locked.
Mom won't let me in.
But it's so hard.
The rat's too fast for me.
The rat's too fast.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys.
Look at this.
The rat's too good.
Look, alright.
Wait!
Oh, I'm a pro gamer!
I'm a fucking pro gamer!
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh, shit!
Yeah!
I did it!
I'm so good!
Wait, do I need to see?
Oh, we don't give a fuck about mom anyway.
Wait, how do I go in?
Oh, I need the bowling ball.
I need the bowling ball.
I fucked up!
I didn't bring the bowling ball!
I forgot the bowling ball.
I forgot the most important part Dude, I'm so fucking good.
I'm so good at this game BAM!
What the fuck are you?
What do I do?
Do I- What do I do?
I- I can't pick it up.
It won't let me- oh, it won't let- okay, what the fuck we
don't give a shit.
Well, I guess we- oh, I guess he's dead.
Oh, I guess my mom's dead too.
I guess my mom's dead.
I
don't know what else to do anymore.
Oh, the shotgun!
I forgot the shotgun in the closet!
You know, I might as well get bored.
Just bored me.
All right, just like, I need the shotgun.
No, no, no, no, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Alright.
Alright, we got this.
We got this.
I got this.
I know what to do now.
My brain has expanded.
I don't care about who else dies here.
I'm just just accepting them for.
Yeah, but what do I need the lights on for?
Like, what do I need the lights on for, though?
There's no reason to have lights on.
My brain has expanded today, guys.
Alright, watch this.
Watch this pro gamer.
Yeah, you thought.
You thought.
I know how to play this game now.
You thought you got this?
I'm better.
I'm a better gamer.
Get the fuck away, mom.
Yeah.
Yeah, mom.
Yeah, get out.
Get out, mom.
All right.
And then I take the shotgun.
all right and then and then bam give me that and then i go
oh well i don't give a fuck about the sister i don't care
about her um okay so first off i need the bowling ball for
the bear trap all right i got all the okay okay we don't
care about the sister like i want to be an only child
save the cat though.
Alright, I'm gonna save the cat.
Break your toilet after getting the trap?
Why?
What does the toilet do?
Yeah, but I don't care about the sister.
That doesn't do shit though, right?
What is this?
Hey, ducky.
How am I doing with a ducky?
Okay, I need this.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Okay, so we got everything we need.
Alright, and then...
We need the bear trap here.
Okay, and then... And I guess I can watch my sister die.
No fucking timing on that!
Okay!
You're the fool!
That's right!
Oh god, that was perfect.
You know, I'll save mom.
I'll save mom.
Who the fuck cares?
I'll save her.
Oh,
that was actually perfect.
That was actually perfect.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we did not give a fuck about the sister.
Please show up so I can chop your hands.
So I can go chop chop chop chop.
Chop chop.
All right, all right.
All we have to do is wait for the dad, right?
We've got everything.
Wait, I have to get shotgun ammo?
Oh, no.
I don't have shotgun ammo.
I didn't know.
No, I told me about the shotgun ammo.
Well, I guess we're going to get bored again, guys.
I guess we're going to get...
No, I told you.
Where do it's the shotgun ammo?
Where's the shotgun ammo?
Okay, there's no shotgun ammo here.
Where is it?
Where
are you shotgun ammo?
Where's shotgun...
No, that is home.
I don't know where shotgun ammo is.
Shotgun ammo?
Oh!
Oh, okay, well...
Well, I tried to find a shotgun ammo and that didn't work.
Well then.
Alright, alright.
This is it.
This is gonna be the run.
We know everything.
Where the fuck's the shotgun ammo though?
Guys, where the fuck's the shotgun ammo?
Please.
I need to know what...
I want this game to be over with.
Where's the ammo?
I just we just we know everything we just don't know one
thing
one our one flaw shot gun ammo
please I want this to be over with all
right all right and then we chop we chop
okay and where the heck there's a gun ammo in the base and
you need to break the face so oh okay all right we got okay
we got all our information we got thank you We needed the
wheel.
I'm tired of getting bored.
I was tired of getting bored guys.
Oh, I forgot to save my mom Did it help me game?
What the fuck do I do with a duck though?
What was the point of the duck you know what you know, I'll
go I'll go break this I'll go break it
You had more moral support All right, duckie, what do I do
with you?
Do I put the, what do I put the duck next to, I'll put the
duck next to the trap.
Oh, pfft.
Oh, you just chuck it, apparently.
All right.
Okay, there we go.
I don't care about you.
Oh, sandwich time.
And then pick up the sandwich.
I don't know what to do with that.
And then...
Boop.
And then, oh, why?
Alright, and then we gotta save Ducky.
Alright, and then we gotta break the vase.
Boop.
And then, one...
Alright.
Cat?
I need you to...
Okay, okay, and then...
Ooh!
How do I load the gun?
Is my gun loaded?
Alright, I'm gonna assume my gun's loaded.
I'm gonna assume...
Alright, we got everything!
We got everything!
One bullet we okay, maybe I don't maybe I need more than one
bullet.
Maybe I need more than one bullet Maybe I need more than one
bullet, you know, I don't trust myself.
Okay, all right.
All right, all right, all right I sort of don't trust myself
here
Oh, oh, I'm sorry Oh, no, I killed the rat
the rat.
God damn it.
I chopped the rat.
I was unperfect and then I killed his children.
He didn't...
We almost had the right.
I had to chop the child.
I...
I had to chop this child.
I'm I'm sorry.
Oh wait, it's the other option.
This bird has changed you.
I'm sorry, I just wanted to fucking...
I just wanted to chop the...
Chop the fog.
Oh, you bitch!
Okay, and then chop chop.
Chop chop.
Oh, I should, I should, like, put this down first before I
chop chop.
Alright, chop chop.
Alright, bye, mom.
Okay.
Chop,
chop.
Alright, alright.
There we go.
We got the speed run.
Do I even need?
Do I even need this?
I don't really need it.
As you're holding the axe you're holding.
Okay.
I don't need you, sister.
I don't need you.
I just need...
I just need ammo.
So I'll load my shotgun.
Oh, can I kill her?
Oh, okay, no.
Alright, bye.
And then...
Oh.
No, that's okay.
We don't need to save her
Here, take the sandwich How do I shoot it?
Oh, okay, wait Oh, Shadow Mad, please Shadow Mad, please
Please, Shadow Mad, I just want to do this Woo!
Shadow Mad, please Let me, I need more ammo!
Alright, two shotgun.
There we go.
Two shots.
We got this.
Two shots in a dream.
Oh, cat!
Cat, cat, cat, cat, cat!
Cat!
There we go.
All right.
Do we say mom?
Let's just say mom for now.
Let's just say...
We're seriously...
Take doll to his sister?
No, that's okay.
I know, we don't need the sister.
We don't need the sister.
Yeah, bitch.
Alright, alright, we got everything we need.
We have the shotgun.
There we go.
Okay, okay, we have everything.
We got everything we need!
Dad, come up!
Come here, Dad!
Dad!
Woo!
Shadow!
Alright,
alright, alright, alright, daddy.
Alright, dad.
I know I'm lying on Tokyo as a sister.
That's why I'm an- why do you think I'm an only child, guys?
Why do you think I'm an only child, guys?
Alright, alright.
Yeah, come in here.
Yeah!
I just have a mom!
We did it.
It only took us 30 minutes, guys.
All we need was two shots.
Dad's dead.
I get the house.
Oh, I have a cat, too.
I'm a cat, a rat.
I get the house.
The house is mine.
I know, mom.
I guess...
I guess that's alright.
Oh shit, it's time to listen to a daily song.
Okay, wait, wait, let's listen to a daily song.
Let's, like, embrace victory real quick.
The daily song.
Oh, the darkness retreats, but somewhere distant.
A fleshy heartbeat continues.
We did it.
Woo!
It'll be the toast of becoming a girl on the...
We did it!
My sandwiches!
Oh my god, we actually did it!
What the fuck were you?
So you think you've beaten it?
Well I'm afraid you're terribly wrong.
There's no way to stop it.
It never ends.
Whop!
You know what?
You know what, doll?
I'm gonna end it right here.
I close